since the Friday release of the GOP
house Intel memo Democrats and their
lackeys in the lamestream media have
been in overdrive attacking on four
fronts first they downplay the memo it's
a big nothing as the New Republic put it
quotes it would be easy to compare new
nez's memo to Geraldo Rivera opening Al
Capone's vault I was surprised that it
was such a flimsy document on its face
the whole point here is not to be
accurate the point is to be misleading I
don't think that there's much to the
memo now for a memo that is supposedly a
big dud
liberals are sure spending a lot of time
trying to debunk it second they charge
that the memos author Devin Nunez is a
really bad actor and did you know he's
colluding with the White House I think
the president was crystal clear and I
think that especially chairman Nunez is
doing his bidding I believe that this
White House worked with Chairman Nunez
to concoct this idea I think it's very
possible a staff will call the White
House and coordinated the whole effort
with the White House now that's a nice
dodge I love how they're trying to
suggest that the memo is politically
motivated while ignoring the facts in
the memo that demonstrate that the
entire Russia investigation was
politically motivated from its inception
Devin Nunez's work to ensure the
integrity of both the Clinton and the
Muller investigations should be welcomed
by all Americans whatever your political
persuasion and I'll tell you why because
no one should be able to abuse or excuse
the rule of law for political reasons
governments cannot be allowed to target
their political enemies well they do it
though don't they in China and North
Korea and you bet in Russia my question
is what happened to accountability
holding government accountable sir
the Democrats claim that Trump is going
to use the memo to stop the Russia
investigation and maybe even fire deputy
AG rod Rosenstein setting up if rod
Rosen Stein was fired could that trigger
the worst constitutional crisis since
President Nixon's Saturday night
massacre if the president uses this fake
horrible release of distorted
intelligence as an excuse to fire a
deputy acting Attorney General
Rosenstein or Muller it could lead to a
constitutional crisis I'll just tell you
this could precipitate a constitutional
crisis I know there'd be a tremendous
outcry no there'd be a constitutional
crisis I mean this redefines
echo-chamber takes it to a new level
they pass around a memo in the morning
okay we're gonna say cherry-picked one
day then I'm gonna go to constitutional
Christ oh my god and I said kids take it
easy there's no evidence that Donald
Trump is gonna fire Rosen Stein despite
and I understand it his displeasure with
some of Rosenstein stupid decisions
including signing off on one of those
warrants to surveil Carter page but for
just a moment let's accept their silly
scenario now the firing of Rosenstein
may trigger a political fracas and maybe
it would be unwise I wouldn't do it but
the president surely has the
constitutional authority to fire anyone
in the executive branch
so I fail to exactly see how this would
trigger a constitutional crisis finally
the Democrats insist that with the
release of this memo Trump and Nunez are
putting the future of the entire FBI in
jeopardy trying to undermine the FBI and
the Department of Justice is really not
in the best interests of America and the
goal here is to undermine the FBI
discredit the FBI discredit the Muller
investigation do the president's bidding
yes it's a war on fun law this is a war
on justice this is a war on the Justice
Department this is a war on the FBI it's
also a war on understatement Joe now who
is carrying out a war against a
reputation Tegra to the FBI if anyone
did well I'd say it's former Obama AG
Loretta Lynch former Obama FBI director
Jim Comey and former Obama deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe who waged war on
the FBI by damaging its reputation now
how do they do that well they they put
the FBI's future in jeopardy by eroding
confidence in one of our treasured law
enforcement institutions because you
cannot start spying on an American
citizen as some kind of insurance policy
against a presidential candidate you
don't happen to like in fact you cannot
surveil an American citizen based on
falsified evidence at all or by omitting
a material fact in a FISA application
for a warrant but I'll tell you the left
just refuses to address the central
point of the Nunez house Intel memo I
was thinking about this earlier today
when I was hosting my radio show
remember when Democrats used to care
about protecting american civil
liberties post 9/11 the ACLU warned
about various ways the Bush
administration was endangering the Bill
of Rights they warned about the Patriot
Act and growing surveillance Society by
the way I agree and they sounded alarms
over the weakening of the Freedom of
Information Act
by reclassifying documents as
unclassified but sensitive and the
Liberals even complained and some other
civil libertarians about the fairness of
these long no-fly lists but this is my
favorite part of this aclu list of
grievances was number eight political
spying it was called political spying
government agencies including the FBI
and the Department of Defense have
conducted their own spying and on
innocent and law-abiding Americans
through the Freedom of Information
enact the ACLU learned the FBI had been
consistently monitoring peaceful groups
such as Quakers People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals Greenpeace in the
american america american
anti-defamation committee and indeed the
aclu itself
well Peter got surveilled apparently but
I guess Carter page in the Trump
campaign just don't qualify for Fourth
Amendment protections the ACLU has been
kind of silent now there was a time when
Democrats cared about things like FISA
Court abuses FISA Court process is one
of the most one-sided approaches in
American government I know of no other
court that doesn't have some kind of
adversarial discussion where there are
two points of views there should be some
adversarial process challenging it
questioning it just as we do in the
normal course your opinions themselves
will benefit by having an adversarial
process in key cases where the court has
the benefit of hearing the other side of
seeing opposing case law look he was on
RT TV do you see that that's a great
well so they were all worried don't look
at what could happen with the FISA Court
but now however FISA is beyond reproach
as long as it's used toward the ever
noble goal of destroying Donald Trump or
preventing him back then of being
president at all today on my radio show
Newt Gingrich agreed that a criminal
investigation should be undertaken to
discover how the FBI purposely misled
the FISA Court and may have obstructed
justice in the iller Hillary email
investigation I want emphasizes 98% of
all FBI agents are honest patriotic
Americans trying to enforce the law but
they are tainted by the people at the
very top who clearly were corrupt and
we're clearly violating the law this
will lead to a criminal investigation
and frankly I don't understand why the
Attorney General has not taken steps
that's a great great question the
question is with rod Rosenstein in
deputy AG could there ever really be a
special council appointed to explore any
of this or will it be up to Congress to
find all the relevant documents and
forces hand whatever happens there is no
doubt about the following after all
their years of claiming to be advocates
for fairness and civil liberties the
Dems have been outed as frauds of the
worst order and that's the angle